[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on appelle ça du nettoyage là bas on
prend une terre on la brûle et
et puis quand ça a fini de brûler même
parfois ça continue de brûler on y met
des vaches
[Applaudissements]
le système d'agroforesterie assez
vulgairement sait on fait pousser des
arbres césar vont créer de l'ombre et
avec cette ombre va pouvoir faire des
cultures de légumes de fruits et surtout
garder l'eau dans les sols ce qui est
très intéressant dans ces pays où il
fait très très chaud croyez moi d'écrire
un petit peu nombre là-bas nature prend
très vite la place qu'elle doit prendre
dès qu'on lui donne un peu d'ombré petit
peu de soleil et un peu d'eau c'est bah
ça va extrêmement vite c'est assez
fascinant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pu assister à des paysans qui
échanger leurs leurs techniques par
exemple de biopesticides certains
utilisent delahaye certains utilisent
des harris des petits des petits
poivrons un peu comme ça de petits
piments d'autres de la bouse de vache
pour les engrais et chacun était en
train d'apprendre et c'était assez fou
parce que
on voyait vraiment la passion dans leurs
yeux c'est des vrais passionnés faut pas
croire qu'ils sont là juste pour avoir
de la rentabilité dont ils aiment leur
terre ils aiment leur leur forêt il aime
les animaux qu'ils ont et ils sont très
bien consciente que il ya un gros mon
problème
et d'ailleurs il essaye de transmettre
ce message là à leur famille à leurs
enfants et puis surtout alors alors on
va dire leurs collègues paysans qui ne
font pas forcément la même chose qu elle
est vraiment tout à un cercle vertueux
économique à l'agroforesterie ce n'est
pas juste planter des forêts et sauver
la nature c'est être en harmonie avec la
forêt dire oui la fois elle peut nous
donner ça et on peut en créer une
économie plus qu'on est dans un monde où
tout est géré par l'économie ben pas de
soucis vous inquiétez pas ça marche
aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça c'est souvent les femmes qui le
font mais qui le qui se font qu'ils le
font en totale autonomie
et qui s'organise qui font des
associations qui qui se réunissent pour
le faire et ensuite vont vendre ses
produits l'impact social il se retrouve
déjà parlé parlé ces associations de
femmes qui sont de plus en plus
impliquées qui sont aussi sur le terrain
qui avant de rester à la maison et
s'occuper du foyer mais là aujourd'hui
et se trouve une nouvelle activité sont
très épanouie de le faire et on le sent
on le ressent ait une vraie fierté une
vraie émotion et
et surtout une mise de côté
du machisme qui est assez présent dans
ce pays là donc ça c'est très très fort
[Musique]
c'est vraiment tout mettre en place pour
que au bout de quelques années ils
puissent partir et que l'essai en
autogestion le célé le but c'est pas
rester c'est vraiment de les accompagner
ces du développement et ensuite s'ils
partent c'est le sait ça le la réussite
c'est quand ils partent c'est là où ils
sont contents parce qu'il est à dire
qu'ils ont réagi
[Musique]